Virginia implodes Democratic
presidential candidates drop like flies
and the specter of socialism looms I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the venture Pierrot
show oh man I have sitting right here
before me the draft green new deal from
Alexandra Oh Cosmo Cortez I could not be
more excited to explain to you how she's
going to completely rewrite the American
economy revitalize America's industry
it's so good man it is so good plus beta
O'Rourke there's an article about him in
the New York Times and man it's groovy
and everything it's unbelievable but
well gets all that in just a second
first let's talk about what you're doing
for Valentine's Day so you know what the
best Valentine's Day gift ever would be
cherries berries I am not kidding you
okay so Sherry's berries has kosher
goods and very often we have advertisers
on the program who have stuff that is
not kosher and so I talked about how
people in the office like it because
people in the office tell me how great
it is but when it comes to Sheree's
berries they actually have some kosher
stuff so we got a box of cherries
berries at the office and I started
eating this stuff I am now 1,000 pounds
this stuff is unbelievable you're never
gonna go wrong with their signature
dipped Valentine's strawberries dipped
in milk darker white chocolaty goodness
for any discerning palate she will fall
in love with every bite top the decadent
toppings chocolate chips heart and
glitter sparkles it's Valentine's made
easy they arrive fresh with 100%
cherries berries guarantee they ship
anywhere nationally gives sweet some
things to your long-distance love
Valentine's Day is directly around the
corner sent her the Valentine's gift of
her dreams at the price of your dreams
starting at $19.99 plus shipping and
handling which is a great combo you're
sending something awesome and it doesn't
cost you a lot of money which means that
she's gonna love you and you won't be
broke it's amazing plus order now and
make this Valentine's really special by
getting double the berries for just $10
more go to berries calm click on the
microphone enter promo code Ben show at
checkout that is berries calm BERR IES
calm click the microphone enter code Ben
show at checkout it is just awesome
sauce of berries calm enter code Ben
show for the special deal it is so good
ok so we begin today with Alexandra
Ocasio course has well gets of Virginia
in just a second so I'll give you all
the updates but just recently breaking
news she's released a brand new plan a
green new deal plan that changes America
forever
because she's a fresh-faced so fresh so
face so Alexander Oh Cosmo quartz has
gotten a Twitter fight my business
partner Jeremy boring last night Jeremy
made the point on Twitter that I had
made yesterday on the show because we
steal from each other on a routine basis
that's why we make great business
partners he he made the point that she
is in fact not a victim while she has
been claiming to be a victim and
cheering herself for being a woman in
Congress and she tweeted something back
about how the fact that she is the only
29 year old bartender in Congress means
that Congress is just not representative
which makes no sense at all by the way
because if we were just to take a
demographic breakdown out of like 500
people how many are 29 year-old
bartenders maybe one out of 500 people
across America I don't think the
demographics work out that way also it
doesn't make any sense to suggest that
the American Congress is supposed to be
broken down demographically akin to the
American population because we have
majoritarian voting in the United States
53% of voters in the United States are
women which means that if women voted as
a bloc everyone in Congress would be a
woman so that's not how voting works
that's not her representation works but
aoc doesn't know things but she has
great fashion sense and she can make
stuff in an instant pot and she's sassy
so that's all that counts and now she
has a brilliant new green New Deal plan
it is so brilliant that even people on
the Left are laughing at it today
because it's just absurd so she has now
released her a green New Deal plan
here's the overview I love it so much
it's so great because this is the future
guys and if you don't embrace the future
it's because you're afraid of the future
like unbelievable you're unbelievably
afraid of the future like if people
would just think like about 20 years
like down the line um then they would
know that like this is what we have to
like do yeah anyway here is what she
says quote we will begin work
immediately on green New Deal bills to
put the nuts and bolts on the plan
described in this resolution important
to say so someone else can't claim this
mantle that says that right at the top
of the overview so that's pretty great
Lachlan Marquis over at remember which
publication he's with right now he he
has this story says this is a massive
transformation of our society with clear
goals and a timeline the green New Deal
resolution a ten year plan to mobilize
every aspect of American society at a
scale not seen
since World War two to achieve net zero
greenhouse gas emissions and create
economic prosperity for all
it will move America to 100% clean and
renewable energy she's saying this over
ten years and create millions of family
supporting wage union jobs ensure a just
transition for all communities and
workers to ensure Economic Security for
people in communities that have
historically relied on fossil fuel
industries you mean like all of the
industries in the United States
literally all of them and she has ensure
justice and equity from frontline
communities by prioritizing investment
training climate and community
resiliency economic and environmental
benefits in these communities build on
FDR's second Bill of Rights by
guaranteeing a job with just a family
sustaining wage Family and Medical Leave
vacations and retirement security so
this is all part of her plan
everyone in the United States is going
to have a job guaranteed by the federal
government high-quality education
including higher education and trade
schools guaranteed by the federal
government healthy food clean air and
water and access to nature so I guess
we're gonna be busing people out to the
forests high quality health care
guaranteed by the federal government
safe affordable adequate housing
guaranteed by the federal government an
economic environment free of monopolies
and economic security for all who are
unable or unwilling to work unwilling to
work economic security for people who
don't even want to work who just want to
sit around all day watching reruns of
the Golden Girls
economic security provided by the
federal government for those people this
is part of the green New Deal plan now
you may think that I'm a dreamer but I'm
not the only one
what okay we're just getting started
guys I mean this is just the beginning
of the green New Deal plan which as I
say is just spectacular it is just
picked and by the way Lachlan is a
reporter for The Daily Beast it says in
this outline it says there is no time to
waste
the IPCC report said global emissions
must be cut by 40 to 60 percent by 2030
u.s. is 20 percent of total emissions we
must get to zero by 2030 and lead the
world in a global green New Deal now
again this is forgetting the fact that
all of the developing countries are
providing the vast majority of actual
greenhouse gas emissions on planet earth
and that they are increasing their
emissions even as we cut our emissions
and I love this she says Americans love
a challenge this is our moon shot a
couple of things about Americans love a
challenge we do like a challenge
no we don't like the challenge of
burning our house down if somebody comes
up to you on the street like you know
what challenge go home take care of
scene pour it all over your roof and
light a match we're like yeah man I love
a challenge
that's something I'm up for someone
comes up to them and you know what I
have a challenge for you I want you to
take this baseball bat and beat the crap
out of your car just go smash those
headlights break the windshield and
while you're at it make sure that you
set that thing on fire too like you know
what I don't love a challenge that's my
moon shot and what she's talking about
is a complete destruction of the
American economy she's like but
Americans love a challenge we can do it
guys we totally can just well in JFK
said we'd go to the end to thee by the
end of the decade people said impossible
if Eisenhower she released this like
they didn't prove it didn't proofread it
she says if Eisenhower wanted to build
the interstate highway system today
people would ask how we'd pay for it
right because you should always ask how
you're gonna pay for things that's like
an important thing and she says when FDR
called on America to build 185,000
planes to fight World War two every
business leader CEO and general laughed
at him at the time the US had produced
3,000 planes in the last year by the end
of the war we produce 300,000 planes
that's what we are capable of if we have
real leadership I'd like to see like one
iota of evidence that people laughed at
FDR when he said he wanted to build
planes in the middle of a war is there
any evidence that that's true and then
she says this is massive investment in
our economy in society not expenditure
this is my favorite part so we're going
to destroy the entire economy we're
gonna guarantee jobs to everyone who is
unwilling to work we're gonna guarantee
full scale health care higher education
and housing to everyone who is unwilling
to work unwilling to do anything but
that's an investment in our economy in
society it is not in expenditure now
here's why she may be failing economics
when you invest in things there's
usually a return on the investment when
you expend on things you are just
trading your money for the thing now
what she is doing is trading the money
for the thing there is no return on this
investment because it's not an
investment it's a political expenditure
of money that is not hers but that's
okay
that's okay she says we invested 40 to
50 percent of GDP into our economy
during World War Two and created the
greatest middle class the US has ever
seen no okay we invest it so she is now
citing warts
I'm economic spending as a rationale for
economic growth that is asinine you know
what we did during World War two we took
every male in the United States between
the ages of 18 and 45 and we put them in
barracks and we had them live off
rations because we're in the middle of a
war the economic growth that occurred in
the aftermath of World War two was not
caused by government expenditure
government expenditures decreased after
World War two she says the interstate
highway system has returned more than $6
in economic productivity for every one
dollar it caused you know what happened
by the way everybody always wants to
talk about the interstate highway system
you know what to happen if there was no
interstate highway system nothing really
nothing what I mean by that is that
route 66 already existed all that would
have happened is that states would have
connected their highways one of these
people think that the highways just
would have ended at the state line that
there just would have been like a bridge
and then nothing they just went it's a
dead end at the end of the street she
says this is massively expanding
existing and building new industries at
a rapid pace growing our economy and
then she says the green New Deal has
momentum 92 percent of Democrats and 64
percent of Republicans support the green
New Deal right because it doesn't mean
anything until you set all this garbage
now that net support levels gonna go
down to zero it gets better there's a
bunch of frequently asked questions here
and she says why 100 percent clean and
renewable and not just 100 percent
renewable are you saying we won't
transition off fossil fuels yes we are
calling for a full transition off fossil
fuels and zero greenhouse gases anyone
who has read the resolution sees that we
spell this out through a plan that calls
for eliminating greenhouse gas emissions
from every sector of the economy simply
banning fossil fuels immediately won't
build the new economy to replace it this
is the plan to build that new economy
and spells out how to do it technically
as we set a goal to get to Net Zero
rather than zero emissions in ten years
because we aren't sure that we'll be
able to fully get rid of farting cows
and airplanes that fast
you're gonna kill all the cows is that
sad and she said she was to get rid of
airplanes and also farting cows is she
gonna give them all X lakhs how's this
gonna work
says his nuclear a part of this she says
no there will be no nuclear energy so
only the most efficient source of energy
known to man nuclear power note we're
not cutting in clean by the way we're
not gonna do any of that so we're going
to transition all of the energy away
from fossil fuels but there will be no
use of nuclear energy which means that
we will all blow into pinwheel
apparently to produce all of our
energies we'll just Train hamsters and
they will run around on wheels and those
wheels will power our new green economy
says does this include a carbon tax the
green New Deal is a massive investment
in the production of renewable energy
industries and infrastructure we cannot
simply tax gas and expect workers to
figure out another way to get to work so
we're not ruling a giant carbon tax out
but a carbons have to be a tiny part of
a green new deal
well carbon tax may apart and this is
the point it would be off the table
unless we create clean affordable
options first
how about cap and trade well she says
that we there won't be cap and trade
because that assumes that there's such a
thing as a market we don't like markets
and no so how is she gonna do any of
this stuff this is where things get
awesome so wait a second wait until she
gets to you I love it so much she's just
like you know we're gonna do we're gonna
fix everything how are you gonna do it
we just are great plan okay well she
don't guys stop asking questions she's a
fresh-faced very fresh and very face the
back to this in just a second I'm sorry
if this is the best they're not sending
their best they're not sending their
best we have to shut the Democratic
Party down until we can figure out what
the hell is going on okay first let's
talk about how you protect your own home
I'm trying to protect America from this
nonsense but you just want to protect
your house from would-be burglars this
is why you need ring rings mission is to
make neighborhoods safer you might
already know about their smart video
doorbells and cameras that protects
millions of people everywhere ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world so if there's a package
delivery or a surprise visitor you will
get an alert and be able to see hear and
speak to them all from your phone that's
thanks to the HD video and two-way audio
features on ring devices we have a ring
comm device at our house it allows me to
know when somebody's ringing our
doorbell even if I'm 3,000 miles away
and then if it's somebody who I don't
want coming into the house or I think
they're dangerous I can even call
nine-one-one I mean it's really great
and they don't just do that they have
all of these other devices that allow
you to create a ring of security around
your home as a listener you have a
special offer on a ring starter kit
available right now with a video
doorbell and motion-activated floodlight
cam the starter kit has everything you
need to start building that ring of
security around your home you should do
it I certainly have I'm worried about
home security a lot and you should be
too because listen break-ins happen and
and you really should be protected in
the best possible way go to ring comm
/ban then
ring.com /ban once again ring.com slash
pen for your special deal go check it
out ring calm slash man ok back to a
o'seas brilliant fresh-faced 'add new
plan so how will you pay for it
right good question now she already said
that we're not supposed to ask that
question because if we ask that question
it shows insufficient commitment
which is just what my wife says every
time she asks me to buy her an expensive
piece of jewelry I say well how much is
it gonna cost us if you if you care how
much it costs well then you don't really
love me well that's that's what a OC is
doing right now she's like we're like
well this Greenwood deal like hey you
got any plan to pay for any of this
stuff like at any point she's like you
don't love me enough
you just don't if you really care you
wouldn't ask such questions does how
will you pay for it he or she this is so
great the same way we paid for the New
Deal
the 2008 bank bailout an extended
quantitative easing programs the same
way we paid for World War two and all
our current wars so you still think
given an answer because you know what
that was racking up federal debt that's
when we racked up laws have federal debt
right there
she says the Federal Reserve can extend
credit to power these projects and
investments and new public banks can be
created to extend credit oh so we'll
actually even create banks run by the
federal government to lend to the
federal government paid for by the
federal government with dollars that
don't yet exist that we will get from
other countries or we'll inflate our way
this is good it's pretty brilliant
there's no way this goes wrong at all
she says there's also space for the
government to take an equity stake in
projects to get a return on investment
so it won't just be the banks lending
out the federal banks lending out to
capitalistic companies to build all the
screen New Energy stuff we will have
direct ownership in all of these things
we'll nationalize the energy industry
perfect you know where that worked
awesome invent is way ya know at the end
of the day this is an investment in our
economy that should grow our wealth as a
nation so the question isn't how we will
pay for it but what we will do with our
new shared prosperity my favorite line
of the whole thing so great so really
again back to my wife in the jewelry
this is me saying to her so how much is
it gonna cost his listen listen to me
okay this is not an expenditure this
grows our wealth as a household the
question is not how you're gonna pay for
this 100 thousand dollar necklace the
question is what we should do with our
new shared 100 thousand dollar necklace
what the actual okay but but it
continues it continues I love her okay I
love when she gets to her actual goals
her resolution summary her resolution
summary is fan
frickin tastic so again we're talking
about Alexander Ocasio Cortez so fresh
so face her new green New Deal plan
which is in line with all of her other
statements in that it is fully idiotic
she says created in consultation with
multiple groups from environmental
community environmental justice
community and labor community five goals
in ten years
net zero greenhouse gas emissions
through a fair and just transition for
all communities and workers create
millions of high wage jobs and ensure
prosperity and economic security for all
I like how that's just the goal we're
just gonna create these jobs and then
everyone will have prosperity and
Economic Security well now that you've
articulated it that way I think we're
gonna get there guys I'm optimistic
she has invest in infrastructure and
industry to sustainably meet the
challenges of the 21st century clean air
and water climate and community
resiliency healthy food access to nature
and a sustainable environment for all
promote justice and equity by stopping
current preventing future and repairing
historic oppression of frontline and
vulnerable communities but also gonna
stop racism with this by the way isn't
that amazing
all it took was a OC to come and say
stuff and racism got solved guys it was
unreal so good and then she like oh my
god like it's almost hard to believe
that this is a thing that she actually
is suggesting right that she suggests in
this in this plan the there's a bigger
plan that's also been put out I believe
I'm line and in this plan she also
suggests that we are going to get rid of
cars and we are going to get rid of
train we are gonna get rid of airplanes
and replace it with trains I am NOT
making this stuff up this is a real
thing so NPR has a summary of the green
New Deal and at the bottom line and at
the bottom of this summary of the green
New Deal it says a guaranteed job with a
family sustaining wage adequate family
and medical leave paid vacations and
retirement security for every American I
it's all gonna be great guys I totally
totally think it's gonna happen also she
says that she wants to upgrade or
replace every building in the country
every single one
she's repair and upgrade us
infrastructure upgrade or replace every
building in the United States for
state-of-the-art energy efficiency okay
massively expand clean manufacturing
work with farmers and ranchers to create
a sustainable pollution and greenhouse
gas free food system that ensures
universal access to healthy food totally
over this is the best part totally
overhaul transportation ready for this
one here we go I swear it's like
leprechauns
farting while riding unicorns across a
rainbow sky that's that's that's what
this is totally overhaul transportation
by massively expanding electric vehicle
manufacturing build charging stations
everywhere highly specific everywhere
everywhere you look there's a charging
station you look at your closet boom
charging station you go out on the
street boom charging station you go over
to the local Baskin Robbins you open
that door thing you're gonna get
thinking you're gonna get a scoop of ice
cream
boom charging station right your grill a
charging station build-out high-speed
rail at a skill where heirs travel stops
becoming necessary build-out high-speed
rail at a scale where air travel stops
becoming necessary young people got
airplanes you know it's the fun thing
about airplanes really you know it's one
of the fun things they travel in the air
they go real fast and they go from place
to place and then they refuel and keep
going you know it's one of the problem
with trains they're on tracks the tracks
can't swerve the tracks can't move the
tracks are very stable do you think that
it would take longer to take a
high-speed train from LA to New York or
to take a plane from LA to New York I am
sure this is going to go over great guns
and we're going to be spending what
trillions of dollars presumably to build
high-speed trains from like in Japan
Japan is the size of what it's smaller
in California and Japan so she's talking
about doing this across the country so
every time I go from LA to Washington I
think we should just get listen if we're
really committed to the green New Deal
we need covered wagons that's what we
need we need covered wagons then we need
oxen not farting oxen just oxen we need
fart free oxen to take us in covered
wagons across the country on high-speed
trains that's what we need
powered powered by love that's exactly
what it says we're going to create
affordable public transit available to
all with the goal to replace every come
question engine vehicle every single one
so those millions of combustion engine
vehicles that are driving around right
now they'll all be gone within ten years
how stop asking how that shows
insufficient commitment commit yourself
commit yourself to a green new deal or
you don't care about Mother Earth now
when asked about this I am sure she will
say that it is racist to ask about this
she will suggest that it is very bad to
talk in in realistic terms about all
this it shows that we don't care enough
because this is always the response to
people who have questions about stuff
like this whenever we talk about climate
change and folks like me say you know
what I am perfectly willing to accept
that man-made activity is responsible
for a majority of the climate change
that has occurred over the last century
and a half perfectly happy to suggest
that that is the case because that seems
to be a generalized scientific consensus
all right fine now what do you want to
do about it they're like how dare you
you're a climate change denier well all
I asked was what do you want to do about
it
stop stop asking that question it just
shows that you don't want to do anything
which means you're a climate change
denier this is the same thing here's my
green new deal it will provide free jobs
to everyone free healthcare to everyone
free ice-cream to everyone a pony
everything you ever wanted it will
provide you know cool how stop it stop
it you are not freshened and face it
enough to ask such questions so this is
the new if this is the new Democratic
Party the world is stupid but we already
knew that the world is stupid how stupid
is the new Democratic Party the fresh
faces of the Democratic Party
and how this is the party of science by
the way I've been reliably informed that
this is the party of science the party
that says that babies up to points of
birth are not in fact babies there are
clusters of cells and all so that we can
get rid of all planes in the United
States via trains powered by unicorn
crap party of science man party of signs
we didn't get two more on the Democrats
party of science in just a second but
first let's talk about how you improve
your business let's say that you have an
employee like AOC who presents you with
business plans that make no sense at all
and you're like you know what I need a
better employee than this where should
you look probably should check out zip
recruiter hiring can be pretty
time-consuming you post a job to several
online job boards only to get ton
the wrong resumes then you have to sort
through all of those resumes just to
find a few people with the right skills
and experience those job sites that
overwhelm you with the wrong resumes
they are not smart which is why you
should do the smart thing and go to zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire unlike
other job sites zip recruiter finds
qualified candidates for you they're
powerful matching technology scans
thousands of resumes to identify people
with the right skills education and
experience and then actively invites
them to apply to your job so you get
qualified candidates fast it's no wonder
that zip recruiter is rated number one
by employers in the United States that
rating comes from hiring sites on trust
pilot with over a thousand reviews right
now my listeners can try zip recruiter
for free at zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire if you love the show show
your support for it and zip recruiter by
going to zip recruiter comm slash daily
wired GI il wide wi re that zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire zipper
career is indeed the smartest way to
hire alright so the party of science
that says green new deal paid for by
nothing and also babies don't exist now
is making the case I kid you not that
men and women are biologically the same
not that gender is a social construct
disconnected from biology but that
biology suggests that men and women are
exactly the same who is saying this none
other than another fresh face of the
Democratic Party so fresh so face
representative Ilhan Omar Democratic
congresswoman from Minnesota she is now
recommended that he Minnesota Attorney
General keith Ellison investigate USA
power lifting for barring biological
males from women's events omar calls it
a myth a myth that men who identify as
transgender women have a direct
competitive advantage and copied keith
ellison on the letter with a
recommendation that they investigate
this discriminatory behavior omar sends
her letter on behalf of JC cooper a
biological male who identifies as a
transgender woman and who mom are
identified as one of her constituents
she signed the letter on january 30th
31st although it only became public on
Tuesday after Cooper posted a picture to
Instagram here is what the letter said
it said I am writing to express my
concern over a recent decision by USA
powerlifting to bar participation by any
constituent because she is transgender
under the Minnesota Human Rights Act
discrimination against anyone based on
their gender identity is illegal
this includes in public accommodations
and in Minnesota organizations such as
USA powerlifting in fact just last month
Minnesota jury awarded miss Christina
Ginther $20,000 after the Independent
Women's Football League refused to allow
her to participate because she is
transgender I urge you to reconsider
this discriminatory unscientific policy
and follow the example of the
International Olympic Committee the myth
that trans women have a direct
competitive advantage is not supported
by medical science and it continues to
stoke fear and violence against one of
the most at-risk communities in the
world
so in powerlifting biological men who
identify as women do not have an
advantage over biological women who are
women that's a myth because what what
like really men are only good for a
couple of things one is hitting thing
and the other is picking up big objects
every so often we squash a bug that's
pretty much what we're good for but
according to ohon Omar science science
suggests that men do not have a
competitive advantage in powerlifting
we're not even talking about like ice
skating
what about powerlifting party of science
man these folks are really on top of it
got you got to admire you got to admire
the the security of knowing that no
matter what idiotic thing you say the
media will defend you I mean how secure
do you have to be to put out stupid
ideas like this and know that the media
are going to continue to call you a
democratic fresh face filled with great
ideas for the future of the country
putting out ideas like this and knowing
full scale that the blowback is only
going to come from conservatives and
from people in media who don't happen to
be motivated leftist which is like five
people it's it's gotta be great I mean
that's got to be just a charmed life
doesn't it those of us in the
Conservative comment area we spend every
waking minute thinking about where the
next attack is gonna come from from the
media because this is what they do on a
routine basis every Conservative
politician thinks this way to if you're
a Democrat basically life is a musical
you're walking around people are dancing
in the background usually the Washington
Post reporters every so often Tom Hanks
pops out of the woodwork to give you an
endorsement it must just be fabulous
imagine that a Republican Congress
person said half the
that Ilhan Omar had said oh wait we
don't have to imagine Steve King did you
know what happened he got destroyed by
people including people like me on the
conservative side of the aisle it but if
you're a Democrat man you can get away
with pretty much any stupid idea you
could possibly push it's really amazing
and there is no here's the thing about
being on the left there is no Overton
Window for the left there is no idea
that it's too wild for the left to
actually wrap its arms around and
embrace if only for a moment have a
one-night stand with the left will
embrace any crazy ideas on the right the
Overton Window is really small and the
left helps shrink the Overton Window so
that if you say things like Western
civilization is superior to other
civilizations this may be outside the
Overton Window but if like Farhad Manjoo
and opinion columnist at the New York
Times you write a column called abolish
million billionaires abolish
billionaires then total that's inside
the Overton Window no problem at all
this article says last fall term Choka
editor of The Essential blog Moon Daily
is not that essential nobody's heard of
it wrote a tiny searing post that has
been rattling around my head ever since
there's not a lot in there so I mean
once there's like a thing in there just
kind of rattles some ideas about how to
make the world better require careful
nuanced thinking about how to best
balance competing interests you began
others don't
billionaires are bad we should
presumptively get rid of billionaires
all of them you don't have this idea
Stalin you can liquidate them and take
their wealth that would be one way of
getting rid of billionaires but that's
not what they're talking about what they
are talking about is kneecapping the
wealthiest among us this is the language
in the new york times a billion dollars
is wildly more than anyone needs even
accounting for life's most excessive
lavishes it's far more than anyone might
reasonably claim to deserve however much
he believes he has contributed to
society again you don't seize wealth for
yourself you idiots
you don't become a billionaire by saying
you know what today got up in the
morning decided I'm gonna be a
billionaire and then you just go out and
you steal people's wallets until you're
a billionaire
that's not how being a billionaire works
unless you're a socialist in which case
you could do that right I mean if you're
like Google Chavez you can make yourself
a billionaire just by seizing everybody
else as wealth so I guess for socialists
who believe that all economics is a
zero-sum game the only way to become a
billionaire is by exploiting other
people but for those of us who live in a
free-market world of free exchange
and mutual labor chain mutual labor
exchanges you become a billionaire by
engaging in lots of voluntary
transactions with people who want the
thing you are providing but apparently
this is immoral that's immoral now what
makes transaction one different morally
from transaction 1 million morally what
really what is the moral difference
between Burger King selling its first
hamburger and Burger King selling its 1
millionth hamburger the answer is
nothing it's the exact same transaction
there is no moral difference but for the
left with every incremental sale of a
burger that makes the people who own
Burger King richer it becomes a less
moral act to sell the burger to a
willing customer that's nuts
so here's what Farhad Manjoo again the
New York Times editorial board my
goodness what a repository of idiocy he
said at some level of extreme wealth
money inevitably corrupts why don't you
tell us which level which level makes
you corrupt I've had money I've had not
a lot of money when did I become corrupt
when did I mean I know several
billionaires by the way when did they
become corrupt some or great summer
jackasses
just like every other human being when
it does poverty corrupt because I've
heard it both ways so apparently if
you're too wealthy then you're corrupt
and if you're too poor you're corrupt
because you're poor so if you're too
wealthy you're corrupt because at a
certain point that 10 millionth dollar
made you corrupt and evil unless your
Oprah in which case you're awesome
you know it's except Oprah from this
exempt Oprah but if you're poor if you
don't have enough money that also makes
you commit crimes and mistreat women and
knock people up in all this in a second
we're gonna talk about abolishing
billionaires again this is the new
democratic party man Wow Wow no wonder
people voted for Trump just to stop this
nonsense
okay coming and we're gonna talk about
that in a second first we need to talk
about you saving money okay so you live
in the real world where money doesn't
grow on trees and you can't just
magically transform airplanes into
magical trains the travel high-speed
across the country you need to save the
money you have and this is why you need
to be using honey everyone should be
able to agree about this regardless of
politics with millions of sellers on
Amazon selling the same products how do
you know if you're really getting the
best price you don't unless you use
honey as you shop on Amazon honey's best
price finder automatically compares the
prices of millions of sellers that carry
the item you want honey even factors in
shipping sales tax and Amazon Prime
status to make sure that you are getting
the lowest total price it shows you the
best deal every time even if Amazon
doesn't it's like
your very own smart chopping assistant I
love honey I use it for every purchase
that I make I'd saved a bunch of money
at various sites around the internet
every time you hit a checkout box
like you don't have to start the site
every time it just runs in the
background every time you check out on a
site honey immediately scans the
internet to make sure that you're
getting the best deal more than 10
million people are using a honey to save
money so next time you are shopping on
Amazon treat yourself to a free upgrade
that guarantees you always get the
absolute best price add honey for free
at join honeycomb slash men that is
joined honeycomb slash band go check it
out honey the smart shopping assistant
that helps you save time and money join
honey calm slash Ben go check that out
right this very instant we will get back
into the stupidity of abolishing
billionaires and as I can first go over
to subscribe at daily wire comm for
$9.99 a month you can get a subscription
to daily wire comm when you do you get
the rest of the show live you get the
rest of clayvin alive noses show live
two additional hours of me a day look at
me I'm running down because a few people
I'm providing you like four or five
hours of content today much of it behind
the paywall the least you could do is
engage with our live radio show every
afternoon that's all we ask and then you
can ask questions of me during the
breaks and we can talk we can become
friends I'll come to your birthday party
maybe probably not but maybe you never
know you can go check that out for $9.99
a month or $99 a year which is cheaper
if you do the math if you actually know
how to do math unlike Democrats then you
would know that ninety-nine dollars a
year is cheaper than $9.99 a month if
you were to prorate that over the course
of the year right you see how that works
because it's basic simple division you
also get this the very greatest in
beverage vessel the leftist tiers hunter
cold tumbler look at how the light
glints off the silvery letters of
leftist here's hot or cold tumbler
itched hand etched by blind nuns in the
Alps it's just incredible go check that
out right now leftist here is hot or
cold you got that when you get the
annual subscription also check us out at
YouTube in iTunes because we have things
like these Sunday special this Sunday we
have on famed actor Gary Sinise he stops
by Lieutenant Dan from Forest Gump
we chat about everything art movie play
and military related because he has a
brand new book out and he is one of the
great Pro military voices in the country
right now so stop by on Sunday for that
particular conversation we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so back to fire had Manju he's making
the case that we should abolish
billionaires we should we should do away
with the cool acts he says that some
extreme level of wealth money inevitably
corrupts he says I cover technology an
industry that belches up a murder of new
billionaires annually because that's
what happens that's how millionaires and
billionaires are created is that the
earth just belches them forth like the
uruk-hai from Lord of the Rings just
sort of the earth opens in Mark
Zuckerberg Springs out now if that were
the case I too would be horrified but
that is not actually how billionaires
are made he says much of my career has
required a deep anthropological inquiry
into billionaire dumb but I'm
embarrassed to say I had never before
considered the idea that if we aim
through public and social policy simply
to discourage people from attaining and
possessing more than a billion in lucre
just about everyone would be better off
in my defense back in October abolishing
billionaires from felt way out there it
sounded radical impossible maybe even on
American but it is an illustration of
the political precariousness of
billionaires that the idea has since
become something like mainline thought
on the progressive left yes it does
demonstrate that you are all nuts you
have all lost your freaking minds that
whatever moral fiber you had has been
crapped out and it flushed away into the
sea my goodness Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren are floating new taxes
aimed at the super-rich representative
aoc who also favors higher taxes on the
wealthy has been making a moral case
against the existence of billionaires no
she hasn't she just says it's immoral
for society have to have billionaires
also we're going to need these
billionaires to turn over a bunch of
their money every year and continue to
produce all of that money so that we can
pay for all of my garbage programs
Farhad Manjoo says I suspect the
question is getting so much attention
because the answer is obvious nope
billionaires should not exist now has he
even made the case why they shouldn't
exist or is it just like I don't like
the people have lots of money so far I
have not heard any case why billionaires
should not exist because you have to
make a case that billionaires should not
exist while at the same time maintaining
that free market exchange the better is
everyone who is involved is good you
cannot have those two things at the same
time either I am in control of my labor
and my time and my goods and my services
or I am NOT if you suggest that it is
good for me to do all of those things up
to the point where I make a lot of money
then what you are really saying is that
it is not good for me to do all of those
things beyond a certain point the
transactions become a
negative beyond a certain point which
closes down productivity which prevents
free exchange which makes goods and
services more expensive I mean this is
basic forget econ 101 this is basic
morality and basic human logic but those
have gone out the window a long time ago
this is billionaire about abolition for
us is billionaire abolishment he means
abolition could take many forms
it could mean preventing people from
keeping more than a billion in booty but
more likely it would mean higher
marginal taxes on income wealth and
estates for billionaires and people on
the way to becoming billionaires those
policies ideas turn out to pull very
well even if they're probably not
actually redistributed of enough to turn
billionaires into sub billionaires well
shock when you pull idiots about whether
to take other people's money everybody's
like yeah and most people are kind of
idiots it's it's actually just across
the aisle everybody's stupid and if you
pull if you pull me and should we take
my business partners money I happen to
like my business partner but if I did
not I'd be like sure right if you pull
me on just a base ed level should we
take
should we take all the money away from
like Jane Fonda yeah why not man but on
a moral level no you shouldn't take away
Jane Fonda's money even if she's a
disgrace to her to her fame more
important says Farhad Manjoo aiming to
abolish billionaires would involve
reshaping the structure of the digital
economy so that it produces a more
equitable ratio of the super-rich to the
rest of us
inequality is the defining economic
condition of the tech age we're seeing
these effects now a few superstar
corporations many in tech account for
the bulk of American corporate profits
while most of the share of economic
growth since the 70s has gone to a small
number of the country's richest people
also you get a lot of great stuff and
you Farhad Manjoo gets to write for a
living on a computer provided by
somebody else on a program provided by
somebody else using an internet that is
presumably you're sending your columns
in via Google and all of this is idiocy
it's just idiocy he says Asmus Ocasio
Cortez put it in a conversation with
Donaghy C codes I'm not saying the Bill
Gates or Warren Buffett are immoral but
a system that allows billionaires to
exist when there are parts of Alabama
where people are still getting ringworm
because they don't have access to public
health is wrong I love it he quotes that
and then he has to say in parentheses
human hookworm she later corrected right
because she's dumb and the entire
statement is dumb last week to dig into
this
of whether it was possible to be a good
billionaire I called up two experts I
love this the first was Peter Singer the
Princeton moral philosopher who has
written extensively about the ethical
duties of the rich mr. singer told me
that in general he did not think it was
possible to live morally as a
billionaire although he made a few
exceptions mr. gates and mr. Buffett who
have pledged to give away the bulk of
their wealth to philanthropy would not
earn mr. singer scorn I think we should
totally take Peter singers word for it
you know why because Peter singers other
famous ethical position is that you
should be able to kill babies until they
reach a point of sentience meaning you
should be able to kill newly born
infants until they hit like 2 or 3 years
old I'm not making that up that is Peter
singers actual position we should
definitely take his advice on destroying
billionaires taking away their wealth
and preventing economic growth that has
accrued largely to the world's poorest
let's be real about this we are in in
our lifetimes we have watched the
abolition not of billionaires but of
global extreme poverty that is a result
of free-market capitalism a Peter Singer
says different a man that guy knows
stuff I mean he's fine with like Spartan
killing babies that whatever man he
quotes Peter singer and then he quotes
writer a nun harada harada so i've never
heard of as many billionaires approach
philanthropy as a kind of branding
exercise to maintain a system in which
they get to keep their billion so in
other words if a billionaire gives
charity it's inherently bad unless they
have intense and now we're going to
explore their intent but we're not going
to suggest the billionaires themselves
are bad generally without exploring
their intent but they are bad generally
without exploring their intent and then
he says his second expert on the subject
is Tom Steyer okay Tom Steyer is a
democratic idiot who has tried multiple
times to launch a run for presidency but
no one wants to hear from him because he
is terrible he says mr. Schneider takes
every liberal box he favors in wealth
tax he and his wife have signed The
Giving Pledge he doesn't live
excessively lavishly he drives a Chevy
Volt still I wondered what I got on the
phone with him last week wouldn't we be
better off if we didn't have to worry
about rich people like him trying to
alter the political process mr. steyr
was affable and loquacious he spoke to
me for nearly an hour about his interest
in economic justice and his belief in
grassroots organizing I'm sure he did he
has nothing better to do literally no
one wants to hear from him except for
you Farhad Manjoo
he says at one point I compared his
giving with that of the Koch brothers
and he seemed genuinely
pained by the comparison I understand
about the real issue of money in
politics he said we have a system I know
is not right but it's the one we got and
we're trying as hard as possible to
change it I admire his zeal but if we
tolerate the supposedly good
billionaires in politics we had never
inevitably leave open the door for the
bad ones and the bad ones will overrun
us when American capitalism sends us
it's billionaires it's not sending its
best it's sending us people who have
lots of problems and they're bringing
those problems with them they're
bringing inequality they're bringing
injustice and they're buying politicians
and some I assume are good people what a
bunch of moral drivel welcome to the new
left this is the new left just just
incredible just I mean what do you say
to the base route immorality of all of
this the idea that you're gonna
completely restructure people's lives
against their will because you're no
better than they do and in the process
make people poorer because let's face it
if you start creating disincentives for
people to become rich they are not going
to want to do the work to become rich so
you want to abolish billionaires and
also make it free not to work it makes
perfect sense none of this is gonna go
wrong in any way meanwhile let's get to
the political controversies of the day
because these big ideas I think are in
fact more important but the political
controversies of the day remain Virginia
continues to be a disaster area with the
top three Democrats in the Democratic
Party in meshed in controversy you've
got Virginia Governor Ralph Northam who
was in a blackface controversy from 1985
and that was directly after saying he's
fine with killing babies Democrats fine
with maybe killing very very upset at
the blackface controversy from 1985 then
you've got Lieutenant Governor Justin
Fairfax enmeshed in a sexual assault
scandal one problem there's no actual
corroborating evidence at this point but
that's not the standard for Democrats
they say that believe all women so if
that's the case he's gone too and then
you got the Attorney General Mark
herring who came forward and said in
1980 when he was 19 he dressed up as a
rapper and darkened his face to do so by
his own standard he said that Ralph
Northam had to leave by his own standard
he has to leave too but none of them are
going to leave because the idea that
this is a deep matter of principle goes
out the window of a Republican or to
actually take that slot which the next
person in line is a Republican so all of
that is hilarious we will keep an eye on
it as it develops over the course of the
day in the end
no one's gonna leave everybody will just
shy it shy it off people will say that
you know this made me
but what would be worse is having a
Republican in office so principle
lasting just as far as the edges of the
Democratic Party meanwhile Democratic
contender after Democratic contender
falling like flies my goodness
so Elizabeth Warren yesterday got
herself in some trouble because it
turned out over the last couple of days
that she'd actually filled out official
forms claiming to choose a Native
American then yesterday she says well
maybe I identified as an American Indian
on other applications hmm just as we
have suspected senator Warren it's
important enough I'm not a tribal
citizen and I should have been more just
more mindful of the distinction with
tribal citizenship and tribal
sovereignty and that is why I apologized
to chief Baker and why I've made a very
public apology it was based on my
understanding from my family stories but
family stories are not the same that has
tribal citizenship okay and then she was
asked well did you do this in other
forums and she was like
by the way if you have like a who does
that who's like you know my family story
is that once a long time ago there was a
member of our family who was still in
the race
therefore I put it on a government form
who does that really who is that a thing
I've never heard of that before
frankly that seems to me a lot worse
than what the the Virginia Attorney
General Mark herring did when he dressed
up as a rapper in 1980 I am finding it
amusing that all of these members of the
left media are now suggesting the
dressing up as a celebrity who was black
is a very bad thing but Joy Behar can
stay Tom Hanks can stay Sarah Silverman
can say Jimmy Kimmel can stay all these
folks can stick around even though they
all did this they can all stay but megyn
kelly had to lose her job because she
might have mentioned at one point the
actual reality that there is a
difference in intent between someone who
dresses up as Diana Ross and Al Jolson
singing mammy in black face in a
minstrel show in 1917 so megyn kelly
said a thing Joy Behar did it and showed
it on air in 2016 no problem now there's
no double standard with regard to these
things at all and meanwhile Amy
Klobuchar who was kind of the the great
moderate hope for people who are not
insane in the Democratic Party she's
already getting slammed with oppo at
least three people have withdrawn from
consideration to lead senator Clara's
nascent 2020 presidential campaign and
have done so in part because of the
Minnesota Democrats history of
mistreating her staff according to The
Huffington Post club HR plans to make an
announcement about a potential
presidential bid on Sunday in
Minneapolis has spent the past several
months positioning herself to run for
president
she's beloved in her state as a smart
funny personable lawmaker and has gained
national attention but some former club
HR staffers all of whom spoke to
Huffington Post on condition of
anonymity described clappa try a bit
chilly demeaning and prone to bursts of
cruelty that make it difficult to work
in her office for long so we've been a
fond farewell to Amy clop char before
she even launches her campaign
everything is going great inside the
democratic party primaries all good
stuff all the way across the board so
Elizabeth Warren out Amy claw batch are
in trouble
cory booker idiot so i guess he'll stick
around for a while obviously Kamala
Harris is the person who is leading at
the at the in the clubhouse turn it is
it is Kamala Harris in the lead by a
fairly large stretch
Joe Biden may jump into any minute that
will shake up the race a little bit but
it is pretty obvious this is going to be
a vicious primary and that will make it
really amusing to watch I mean I'm
looking forward to that part aren't you
already time for some things that I like
and then we'll get to some things that I
hate so things that I like there's a
piece of art from 1818 that is
considered sort of the the Enlightenment
view of humanity and I kind of love it
it's a piece by Caspar David Frederick
was from 1818
it's called wanderer above the sea of
fog if you can't see it you look it up
online later or subscribe then you'll be
able to see it it's a picture of a man
standing over a valley with fog all the
way into the distance receding and this
is sort of the idea that human beings
are have the capacity to reach a summit
and then gaze out over the misty
recesses of the universe and we can't
fully understand it but it's our it's
our idea it's it's our job to try and no
it's hard job to try and no that is an
idea that is steeped in biblical
thinking now there's a lot of folks who
think that the Enlightenment was a
complete break from biblical thinking
that it was a rejection of the Bible it
was reason over revelation and all the
rest of that that is simply not true
it's simply not true
there was an Enlightenment that was sort
of the French enlightenment and then
there was the Scottish / British /
American enlightenment which continued
to hold fast to the generalized values
of the Bible the idea of human beings
having free will the ideas of human
beings have a duty to explore the
universe the sort of Francis Bacon
Thomas Aquinas ideas that you were
supposed to merge science with a belief
in the in the greatness of humanity and
you know it's that view that has
characterized the West this is this
piece I think is maybe the best
characterization of the view of what
human beings are in the West I love it
in fact I love it so much that I had
somebody paint a riff on it for me
except using this as the basis for a
biblical painting of Moses standing over
the lands of Israel right before his
death before God before God takes him
God shows him the entire land of Israel
so I had this painting done with Moses
looking over the land of Israel and
seeing the future sort of recede into
the distance sprinkle all right other
things that I like so I talked about
this a little bit on my radio show
yesterday you should subscribe so that
you can hear that live right we do two
hours every afternoon but in case you
missed it I want to recap it for you
there is one of my favorite pieces in
all of New York Times history over at
the New York Times
it's about Beta Beta arc now
you know how much I enjoy beta O'Rourke
is a candidate what I enjoy most about
Peter O'Rourke as a candidate is that he
never really progressed beyond being the
douchebag in high school who would strum
three chords on the guitar all the girls
like oh maybe like watch this stairway
to heaven dudududu dude that was that
was beta O'Rourke and the media loved it
too because the media are a bunch of emo
tool bags and then the media look at
beta are working they say wow he's just
like me he's had struggles too now his
struggles generally consisted of growing
up pretty powerful and wealthy going to
an Ivy League college and then having to
find himself yeah
but that's half the New York media so
Matt flegenheimer over at the New York
Times describes it all at once New York
City seemed to be conspiring against
bethe O'Rourke his girlfriend was moving
to France his punk band mates had
scattered 23 and searching with an Ivy
League degree that could not pay rent
mister o'rourke subsisted as a live-in
nanny on the Upper West Side with a
futon in the maid's quarters watching
over a wealthy families two preschoolers
yes clearly this is a man who has
suffered clearly this is a person who
has overcome obstacles like his
girlfriend leaving to go to France and
also his punk band mates breaking up
with him just just terrible great things
were not happening by late 1995 mr.
o'roarke had fallen into the deepest
depression he can remember he worked for
an uncle's tech business because it was
a job he spent nights alone listening to
his cassettes because it passed the time
little bit of a sad case mr. O'Rourke
said more than two decades later loyally
after what his friends described as a
quarter life crisis mr. O'Rourke has
arrived in a midlife crossroads of
enormous consequence with revealing
parallels to his time in New York
46 and searching after a narrow Senate
loss in Texas last year that propelled
the former El Paso congressman to
democratic stardom he has been driving
around the country alone introducing
himself to strangers deciding if he
wants to run for president so there's
the long piece about how it parallels
his time in New York when he likes sit
in his room
and look at his posters on the wall of
his favorite punk bands and then strum
the bass lines who smells like teen
spirit and just sit there and sing to
himself and think about life and the
existential possibilities of death
though he has described himself as stock
in and out of a funk
he has compared the present reckoning to
moments of ruthlessness in the city when
he last found himself out of work I just
didn't ever want to feel like that or be
in that place or that position again
so that lately has felt kind of strange
maybe with some echoes and that's when
he started that's when he started
singing smells like teen spirit hello
[Music]
that's what he's been doing around Texas
he actually it's real weird he's just
throwing up two individuals on the on
the street and he just pulls a guitar
not he doesn't carry a case he just
pulls it right out of his pocket like
Mary Poppins and there's the bass I mean
like dude I just need assess if you
could help me like change this Terry's
like no let's talk about life and
whether I should run for president for
president that's that's what I want to
talk about man this guy one of the
frontrunners yeah so that element he
says I'm not great solo
I need people he's he's great he seemed
like any other punk minded student draw
a box t-shirt hair past his shoulders
and a grim insistence that the Smashing
Pumpkins had grown pretentious I told
you as a douche bag man bag college
friends say mister o'rourke had settled
on the outlines of an identity that
would last a rebel in moderation more
puckish than unruly he said he chose
Columbia in part because of the
financial aid package and in part
because he looked up to his bohemian
uncle mr. Williams who had tapped into
New York's music scene before that mr.
o'roarke had attended boarding school in
Virginia largely to create some distance
from his father a political obsessive
who did not understand his son's musical
leanings now mr. Roark had run of the
city he went by Robert bata was a
nickname from El Paso owing to its
border town bilingualism and he played
the guitar establishing himself as the
school's gentle punk rapper punk rocker
when a bandmate in a group called swipe
adopted a belligerent performance
persona telling crowds they were
listening to angry swipe mister o'rourke
protester from the stage who's like
we're nowhere now we're not angry the
band member Ellen wieder said it made
him very uncomfortable that I was mean
offstage mister o'rourke was a prolific
dabbler straddling disparate orbits he
was socially conscious but not
especially political other than whatever
kind of politics were being talked about
in Fugazi a former roommate said he
often kept the musicians rollicking hour
he liked to drink beer but not in the
Brett Kavanaugh sense oh you mean like
the sense where you drink beer it pretty
sweet
he was an English major skilled enough
with computers to introduce roommates to
the culture of early 1990s chat rooms
once pranking the girlfriend by posing
as a romantically interested woman
online I kind of had a boyfriend the
girlfriend Catherine Raymond recalled
typing back to the person she didn't
know was mr. O'Rourke as he sat in an
adjacent room then she heard a shout
through the wall what do you mean you
kind of have a boyfriend now if a
Republican did that that would be called
toxic masculinity right
posing as a lesbian in order to try and
seduce your girlfriend for your own
turn-on pleasure but mister o'rourke is
cool and rad so that's amazing
and now he's suffering again because
back in New York that was a tough time
but now he's thinking about he's just
thinking about driving down the road he
says I just had this vision of being in
my truck with the windows down I
remember calling my folks and I said hey
I think I'm gonna come back to El Paso
and now beta O'Rourke for president some
solid stuff okay you know what we don't
have time for any things I hate I've
hated enough things today so we're just
gonna wait and save material for later
in the day got a couple of hours of show
coming up later day that's why should
subscribe go check it out or we'll see
you here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam sy events
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wired production
copyright daily wire 20 19